MICHAEL BALDWIN: Hi, everyone.
I'm Michael Baldwin.
I'm a group product manager
in Google Cloud, focused
on AI and industry solutions.
My team leads product management
across several of our priority
industries.
Thanks for joining us today.
The pandemic has clearly
caused a tremendous amount
of rapid change for all of us.
Today, I want to
speak about ways
that artificial intelligence
has helped enterprises
adapt to those changes.
Today I'll cover
trends that we're
seeing as we work with
our customers, the impact
on key industries, and
how AI can be helpful
in these moments of change, with
some specific examples of how
Google Cloud has helped.
As we monitor our own
business, and especially as we
partner closely
with our customers,
there's a number of common
themes related to the pandemic.
First, a number
of industries are
seeing significant
shifts in demand,
along with increased volatility.
Second, with this uncertainty
comes cost pressures
for many businesses.
And as these businesses
adapt, they often
face supply chain uncertainties.
In some cases, suppliers
may be disrupted themselves
by the pandemic.
In other cases, they may
be struggling to keep up
with spikes in demand.
And across the board, it's
becoming much more difficult
to accurately forecast.
Customer support
cases have risen,
with channels like call
centers getting overwhelmed,
and virtual work has become
the new normal for many of us
as people continue
to social distance.
And across the board, from
retail to banking to media
and beyond, we're
seeing companies
accelerate their digital
transformation initiatives.
And today, I'll talk
to you about how
AI is helping with these
digital transformations.
IDC recently said, "no
doubt, the pandemic
is impacting how every industry
is conducting business,
in some industries AI spend
will actually increase."
Why is this happening?
Well, we think the benefits
of AI in the industries
that we'll talk
about today are going
to be amplified by the
pandemic, as we'll discuss
in detail in the next section.
So there are six industries
that I'll talk through today.
Retail and CPG, financial
services, manufacturing, health
care and life sciences, media,
entertainment and gaming,
and the public sector.
So first let's
start with retail.
We're all consumers of
retail in one way or another.
Retailers have seen
massive shifts in demand.
There's overwhelming
demand for food and drug,
while specialty and department
stores and non essentials are
experiencing declining demand.
There's increased need for
visibility into supply chains
and added need to quickly
replenish in demand items.
Also, it's much harder now
to rely on historical data
for demand forecasting.
In addition,
retailers need to be
able to handle an
increase in returns
from e-commerce channels,
and be able to adapt
to using their stores
as distribution centers,
for fulfillment through buy
online and pickup in store.
We also see an acceleration
in digital-first customer
journeys, in some cases, an
abrupt shift from in-store
to online purchasing that puts a
strain on e-commerce platforms,
fulfillment operations, and
customer service and support.
Finally, during these
difficult times,
some retailers
are closing stores
and are hyper focused
on expense reduction
to preserve liquidity.
As COVID-19 accelerates the
transformation to digital,
retailers are looking
for more tools
to personalize experiences
and sell online.
Google Cloud's
Recommendations AI solution
can help retailers adapt to the
changing environment by helping
them sell the right
product at the right time
to the right customer.
As an example of this, one of
our customers, Digitec Galaxus,
saw a 40% increase
in click-through rate
compared to a previous period.
Next, let's talk about
financial services.
In banking, digital banking
has increased rapidly
from 63% in 2019 to 72% today.
When we look at insurance,
almost 50% of insurance agents
cited building new
customer relationships
remotely as the biggest
challenge during COVID-19.
In the payments industry,
nearly 80% of consumers
use contactless payments today.
And finally, the financial
services industry as a whole
is facing new and
creative types of fraud.
The dollar value of attempted
fraudulent transactions
grew 35% in April,
year over year.
We've been working
with our customers
using our Document AI
technology to help.
For example, with
mortgage rates low,
there's a surge in
mortgage applications.
Using Document AI, we've created
a bundle of specialized models
focused on specific document
types used in lending,
and are working with
lenders to speed up
the processing of
paper-intensive mortgage
applications.
Also, when the US Congress
authorized the Paycheck
Protection Program, or
PPP, earlier this year,
we made the same technology
available to help
with the processing
of PPP loans.
Next, in manufacturing, like
in many of these industries,
there's increased
cost pressures.
Also, workforce
capacity is expected
to decline due to things
like age, absenteeism,
skill shortage, and
economic pressures,
all accelerated by COVID-19.
The pandemic has brought
about an increased focus
on safety and health mandates.
And finally, as many
of these manufacturers
are supporting the supply chains
of these other industries,
they themselves are facing
unpredictable demand cycles.
An example of how Cloud AI is
helping related to the safety
and health mandates
that I mentioned earlier
is how our Vision API can
be used for worker safety.
The Cloud Vision API uses AI to
detect objects, motions, text,
and more to help
derive insights.
So for this example,
it can be used
to detect essential
protective gear,
including hard hats, gloves,
face masks and goggles.
Also, it can be used to
detect distancing compliance
from other workers in
close environments,
and to monitor proximity to
machinery in hazardous sites.
The health care
industry has been
on the front lines of many
of the pressures and changes
brought about by the pandemic.
Large health system
saw revenue plummet
in areas like elective care.
And elective care has
been slowly resuming
after a 10-week hiatus, however
smaller hospitals in some cases
are struggling to stay open.
Providers are beginning
to embrace telehealth
with many visits now
being conducted virtually.
And this is a trend that we
expect to largely persist.
Payers have seen a surge
in COVID-19 claims,
however these have been
offset by a reduction
in overall claims.
And payers are working
to adapt their plans
to cover telehealth.
The pharma supply chains
are stretched thin,
and there's a need to transport
time sensitive COVID-19 tests
and vaccines around the world.
And finally, the
industry is moving
to a virtual clinical trials.
So an example of how
cloud AI is helping here,
is how a US hospital used
our Natural Language API
to analyze unstructured
data from patient inquiries
across multiple channels to more
accurately predict and triage
COVID-19 patients.
Next, there's media,
entertainment, and gaming.
If your family is
anything like my family,
shelter in place policies
have increased media
streaming consumption
and gaming.
But content production has
been paused in many cases,
with sports leagues, physical
productions, and major gaming
titles experiencing slowdowns
in production throughput.
Because of the
slowdown in production,
it's more important than ever
to leverage existing content
and find flexible ways
to produce new content.
And all of this like,
in other industries,
is placing additional
emphasis on cost efficiency
and flexibility.
An example of how AI is
helping is the collaboration
between Google
Cloud and Fox Sports
to enable Fox's employees
to seamlessly search video
archives for specific footage
using artificial intelligence.
By surfacing relevant
videos quickly,
media companies are able
to activate library content
faster.
And also, as live
sports come back,
this capability
will allow producers
to more quickly
take library footage
and integrate it
with live clips.
The public sector at
all levels of government
is working to rapidly
modernize the delivery
of essential services,
as millions seek support
for unemployment, health care,
payroll, and public health
measures.
Government agencies and
academic institutions,
just like their counterparts
in the private sector,
are moving to digital platforms
and collaboration tools
to maintain operations.
And amid this rapid
shift, there's
a continued focus on data
privacy and security.
Finally, like we talked about
in other areas of the economy,
governments and schools
are facing cost pressures
and are being asked to
operate with efficiency
and flexibility.
The state of New Jersey's
Department of Labor
worked with Google
Cloud to deploy
an AI-powered virtual chat
bot to provide real time
answers to the 20 most common
unemployment questions.
And we'll talk through some more
examples from the public sector
later.
Now let's go into more detail
with some specific examples
where Google Cloud AI has
been partnering closely
with our customers.
I'll talk about three areas.
First, Contact Center AI,
including virtual agents.
Second, applying our
Lending AI solution
to the Paycheck
Protection Program.
And third, how new
features in Google Meet
have been supporting
remote work.
First, let me share a quick
overview of our Contact Center
AI solution.
Contact Center AI helps deliver
exceptional customer service
and increased
operational efficiency
using artificial intelligence.
It does this in a few ways.
First, with Dialogflow, it
automates basic chat and voice
interactions.
Next, with Agent
Assist, it makes
human agents more effective.
And third, with Contact
Center AI insights,
it unlocks insights about call
drivers and customer service
interactions.
As the pandemic took hold and we
saw that many call centers were
becoming overwhelmed, our
Cloud AI teams quickly
built and implemented a
customized Contact Center AI
virtual agent to respond to
questions related to COVID-19.
The rapid response
virtual agent has
been deployed across
government and health care.
I mentioned the state of New
Jersey's Department of Labor
earlier.
In addition, the state
of Illinois' Department
of Employment Security
also used this solution
to address
unemployment inquiries,
with more than 2.6 million voice
and chat interactions handled
by the virtual agent so far.
In health care, Penn Medicine
has enabled 24/7 access
to COVID-19 information
for concerned citizens
using this capability.
Next, Document AI
is a solution that
helps organizations
unlock insights
from their mountains
of documents
using artificial intelligence.
It turns unstructured
data into structured data,
which means you can now
understand it and utilize it.
In the United States, the
Small Business Administration's
Paycheck Protection
Program made funding
available to help businesses
keep their workforces employed
during the COVID-19 crisis.
As you might expect, this
led to a massive increase
in loan applications that
needed to be processed.
Building on top of our
Document AI solution,
we created the Paycheck
Protection Program Parser
to enable lenders to use
artificial intelligence
to extract structured
information from loan documents
submitted by applicants.
This can save time, can
be implemented quickly
and securely, and improves
the customer experience
by making the loan
process more efficient.
Finally, many of us are now
familiar with remote work
as the new normal.
Our customers at Google
Cloud have not only
adopted video for
traditional team meetings,
but have also adopted
video for new use cases,
including virtual all
hands, frontline trainings,
and customer engagement.
In fact, these are all ways
me and my team at Google
have used video just
in the past week,
and we see our customers
doing the same.
However, when you're
having a virtual meeting,
there's nothing more distracting
than noise interference.
Perhaps people chatting in
the background, a colleague
pounding on their keyboard
as they take notes,
or the shuffling of papers.
The Google Meet team has used
AI to limit these distractions
by intelligently filtering out
background noises in real time.
Now we'll play a short video
showing you how this works.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hey, I'm
boarding in a minute.
Sorry, it's kind of loud here.
Hey, I'm boarding in a minute.
But let's dive in real quick.
[END PLAYBACK]
MICHAEL BALDWIN: As you can see,
with artificial intelligence,
we can limit these distractions
and make the meeting much more
efficient.
As another example
of this, earlier we
talked about how the
health care industry
is shifting to telehealth.
For example, the
Cambridge Health Alliance
is an example of a health
system with over 6,000 staff
and 140,000 patients
in Massachusetts
that uses Google Meet to
support staff and caregivers,
and the solution has
become an integral part
of the team's work.
They've conducted more than
1,200 telemedicine visits
to date, and their
teams are conducting
over 1,000 Meet sessions
per day for collaboration.
And that brings us to the end.
So to wrap things up, we know
this is a difficult time.
The pandemic has forced
companies and governments
to evolve at a rapid pace.
At Google Cloud, we're here to
help you reach your goals more
quickly and to adapt to your
unique needs using AI and ML.
And as you can see
from the examples
that we've talked through today,
AI isn't a science experiment.
It's being used to solve real
world problems in business
and the public sector.
Thanks for tuning in.
And we wish you, your family,
your friends, and colleagues
all the best during
these challenging times.
If you're interested in learning
more about any of the solutions
that I discussed
today, you can visit
cloud.google.com/solutions/ai
to get in touch and get started.
We look forward to hearing
from you and thank you.